vertical video is the biggest
opportunity right now we've had multiple
multi-million viewed Facebook reels
Instagram reels of course YouTube shorts
and another ones like Pinterest vertical
video or strategically creating vertical
content that we are able to post in
multiple places we're finding that the
reach is staggering because if it
doesn't do great on Instagram reels it
might do phenomenal on YouTube shorts
sometimes our YouTube shorts seem like
they underperform but then Facebook
reels will get a million views if you're
investing in any kind of content
vertical video and short form video is a
major 2023 trend